jose bereas makes his second start as a
blue jay 22nd on the season win number
eight last time out he's got a very good
era of 3 31 this season
first pitch is cut on and lift it in the
air not that deep the oscar hernandez is
there they make the catch and kiki
hernandez has retired on one pitch
he's got himself a base hit
so the red sox
getting into the hit column a lot sooner
than they did in game number one when
they waited until the fifth inning
there's a fly ball into the outfield
brando grichik is there three fly ball
outs for barrios in the first
tanner houck looking for that first win
it's his first career start at rogers
center tonight
down he goes hacking fastball up in the
way to fan springer
one gone
it's that ball on the ground towards
devers bare hands fires not in time
vladie guerrero hustling out of the box
picks up an infield hit
[Applause]
three two and down he goes hacking 93
miles an hour to strike out simeon
finally
swing and a miss down he goes he struck
him out and he strikes out three
in the first inning
camera back with another curveball and
gets the strikeout
two down
and he does bouncing ball guerrilla
makes a nifty grab and a nice toss to
burrills good teamwork right there
body's been playing great all year at
first no scores we hit to the bottom of
the second
another k
got him to go outside
breaking ball fair ball down the right
field line this will be extra bases
dickerson's around first renfro's throw
in the second not in time
corey dickerson with a one-on-double his
14th double of the season
[Music]
gently hit in the air endeavors will
make the catch to retire the side a
double and a walk but nothing comes to
that
that fly ball is hit high and deep to
right but it's going to stay in the
artists
oscar is there three up three down the
red sox go quietly in there half of the
third
george has been hammering away once he
got healthy
will gobble that up and get him
springer out 5-3 one gone in the third
it's sharply sprawling stabbed ever as
quickly to his feet and gets him
what an outstanding play by devers
they're knocking that ball down putting
his body
in harm's way to get that ball in his
glove
got him to chase and he strikes him out
again
one two three they go
[Applause]
knock down but no play for simeon
on what should be a base hit for verdugo
and if true that'll be his second
base hit into right field
that will send verdugo up to second base
so the red sox trying to get something
going here with two down
there's that fastball
gonzalez still looking for the hook and
burrill's crossed him up
he strikes him out second strikeout
oh what a swing as he covered that
breaking ball and strokes it into left
field
a lead off single here in the fourth he
stayed on that breaking ball and just
stroked it very smoothly in the left
task hernandez hits one to devers he
fumbled it a little bit and bo hustling
gets into second base devers couldn't
come out of his glove cleanly he was
thinking about going to second but beau
was hustling and everest decided to go
to first and take the sure out
that's in there for strike three grechik
will argue that he might have a point
but he fans
two down
bottom of the fourth inning in his
seventh inning game neither club has
scored a run
line drive base it into center field
bows around third here's the throat to
third and the blue jays are on the board
one nothing toronto on the breivik
valera rbi single
and swung on a mist he put him away
toronto whoever grabs the first run
one-nothing blue jays after four
he went around
couldn't check his swing on that
curveball and it'll be the third
strikeout for bereas
change up swinging to miss cordero
strikes out
three strikeouts in a row for barrios
gonna go down hacking here for the
second time as whitlock blows him away
one away
unbelievable he's able to make that
adjustment
84.
breaking bahong and this one is going to
get fair down the left-field line one
bounce over the fence for a ground rule
double
for marcus sibian that's his 30th double
of the season
[Applause]
got him to go
vasquez has to scoot over pick it up and
that's a strikeout so he strikes out
three men
in his return to the hill one man left
another choo-choo pitch
he went after it big sweeping breaking
ball another strike and that's five
strikeouts for jose bereas one down here
is verdugo has been the red sox best
hitter today
swaying at a high fly ball that's well
struck on the run it's grichik all the
way to the wall leaping
and he can't get it that ball is gone
home run alex for dugo his third hit of
the ball game and he has tied it at 1-1
ranking ball what a play by bo can he
throw him out yes he did oh my a run
saving play by beau bechet it's short
stop blatty guerrero panda the one hop
throw no problem at all flashing the
leather it's short this is a base hit
for sure
a one-hop long throw he bounces it to
the body that's it
two on none out he's got to do a job
right here he's got to get this runner
over
squares again and did he burn out and
they got the runner hung up gonzales is
in a rundown and belair will tag him oh
what a big out for the blue jays the
veteran marwyn gonzalez got fooled by
that butt attempt
got him and the runners going and they
got vasquez a strike about thrown out to
end the inning and for some reason
christian vasquez broke for third what
an inning defensively for reese maguire
laddie guerrero he has one for three
here's the pitch to him and a swing and
a high drive in the center field hit his
way back [ __ ] at the wall tk leaps and
makes the play
slamming into the wall just to the left
of the 400 marker and we will go to
extra innings
jonathan araus will be the hitter for
the red sox in the ninth place francie
cordero who runs well is the automatic
runner
bounding ball and through for a base hit
francie coming around trying to score
and he will easily and the red sox lead
it 2-1 here in extra innings
two down guerrero still 90 feet away
with the tying run it's the oscar
hernandez and the 02
[Music]
swing and a miss struck him out and the
red sox win it in game two they win it
two to one they split the double-header